have you heard of the dangerous new
drink that's put in college kids at risk
police arrived to the house to find
students passed out everywhere at just 3
bucks a can you can get very drunk very
fast very cheaply the culprit was
actually legal a potent drink called
four loko it didn't take long for
Washington DC officials to sound the
alarm we must protect children from the
severe and deadly consequences of drinks
like for local Senator Chuck Schumer
says drinks like Four Loko poses a
unique danger because they mix caffeine
with alcohol the FDA agrees the addition
of the caffeine does not meet our legal
standards for safety there's very little
evidence to back up the idea these
products pose unique danger Jakub Solem
is a senior editor of Reason magazine
there are two studies - a grand total to
which the FDA cites to show that
drinking caffeinated alcoholic beverages
is especially dangerous but Solem says
neither study proves that drinking four
loko makes college students Loco
it could be the college students drink
the stuff only after they've decided to
go Loco so they're attributing to the
caffeine something that might actually
be due to the predispositions of the
people who are attracted to these
products the combination of alcohol
caffeine is something that's quite
familiar it's nothing though well people
have been doing this for many years with
drinks like rum and cola Irish coffee
more recently with things like Red Bull
and vodka there's nothing inherently
dangerous about it but don't tell that
to reporters why is this legal I guess
that's a whole other conversation
actually it's not legal we have
determined that these products are not
in compliance with the law eventually
the federal government forced four lokos
maker to pull its product by
mid-november the company then removed
the caffeine by mid-december I mean you
cannot really understand a moral panic
like this in rational terms what happens
is a particular substance or product is
singled out and it becomes a scapegoat
once it has been validated as a
legitimate concern that Four Loko is
this intolerable threat to the youth of
America then every story gets framed
that way
and then the stories reinforce each
other it's nicknamed black out in a can
a wide-awake drunks black out in a can
wide awake drunks anybody who wants to
get caffeine whether alcohol has lots of
other options I mean you can still mix
Red Bull with vodka you can get still
have Irish Coffee you can still buy all
of these distilled spirits that are on
the market that have caffeine in them
but even if you aren't it four loko fan
you should still be worried says sell
them if we accept this principle that
the FDA has a none solution which is
that certain products can be banned
because we're afraid that adults
products will abuse them then you know
any product that has any risk associated
with it by that logic might be banned
tomorrow so which should worry us more
mixing caffeine and alcohol or mixing
reporters and politicians for recent TV
I'm Paul Detrick